Howie like your mom got introduced to my
mom you're right i got these yo-yos and
like I think yo-yos are quite fantastic
yeah then we actually ended up making a
Star Wars fan film together in ninth
grade and that was like when I was like
wait your dad is a sweet video camera we
started videos together and started
doing visual effects together and just
kind of stuck with it was one of those
things where we saw the potential right
away like how how many things you could
do using the computer as a visual
effects tool after working it for like
you know just like a year to out for fun
we saw that we were quickly starting to
like accelerate through it and that
there was a ton more stuff to learn and
uncover and figure out and so we just
stuck with it and for every year that we
stuck with it it's just another year of
experience under our belt another year
of knowledge and skill refinement Anala
kinda stuff and so we try to really
focus on learning about all these
different aspects week in which is one
of the great things about YouTube is
many of our videos actually they're half
entertainment pieces but also have
experiments in learning experiences for
us to try all these different things
meet these different people and learn
all these new techniques so when it
comes time to make a bigger project we
actually have something to fall back on
when we say like hey here's I think we
should approach the scene and having
done it before we can talk about you
know all the various points and aspects
that somebody who's very skilled in an
area would be able to bring to the table
and talk about it rather than you having
to say like I don't really know a whole
lot about this so you'll have to do your
best and I hope it's good if you want to
work with people and you don't have a
huge budget don't don't offer him just a
tiny amount of money instead ask them
for a favor because once you if you
asking for a favor and it's the person
that you know say has a skill that cost
a thousand dollars a day they'll come
out and they'll do you a favor because
people are people are in this because
they want to make films they're this
because I want to do what what they're
doing and if you ask them to come up for
a day they'll take their time they'll
donate it and they'll come and work with
you next dictations is that you'll do
the same in return should they need it
but when you say hey I can't pay you
your rate but I can pay you like a
hundred bucks then you're devaluing them
and it really makes like when you do a
favor even though you didn't get
anything it's still very valuable but
when's my phaz 100 bucks didn't just run
hundred bucks so it's kind of learned
very quickly that if you want to make a
cool video we don't have a huge budget
for it it's just gonna be a regular
YouTube video it's it people are happy
to come out and help if we simply just
ask them to we don't need to get into
this hole it's small budget or that kind
of thing if it's it's a small bunch of
film we just say hey we're working on
this project we'd love your help and
then people tend to come out and help
and then the occasional bigger project
comes along where we haven't got a
sponsorship from the video game company
or something like that and then we can
actually pay them their actual rate and
that's that's kind of how we do things
in you know so the budgets fluctuate
wildly but there's a lot of other stuff
I play behind the scenes epicMealTime
online culinary idiotic geniuses we
teamed up with these YouTube magicians
with their fancy camera tricks and
gadgets 75% of this bullsháá even real
it's generating with computer softwares
and internet tubes this isn't even a
person we added it in post-production I
think the all-time was a lot of fun to
collaborate with yeah that was a great
experience just got and get a hundred
hamburgers you know come with funny
ideas and that kind of stuff um hundred
hours is not that much yet apparently
100 and I'd say right now one of the
other people besides that is Clint Clint
Jones he runs the punisher channel he's
actually been working with us in our
studio for a long time and really cool
guy really funny a lot of really good
ideas and he's really good at what he
does as well so we've been finding it
pretty easy to collaborate with him on a
lot of projects he's been in a ton of
our videos along who guys are the one of
the only channels I see where they'll
actually just got and have written
pieces of characters that are addressing
things like relationships and you know
people in
with other people and they're actually
managing to get an audience and give
views with that type of content and
that's very very hard to do and they're
pulling it off so it's their one of the
other groups of filmmakers on YouTube
where I really respect what they do
because it's it's very true filmmaking
what they're doing it's supposed to say
being a personality on camera or you
know talking about ideas and things like
that like they're actually going out at
the shooting scenes that they've written
with characters and then they're not
going crazy with VFX or anything like
that like what we're doing but they're
still you know really hooking something
in people and making people want to
watch some of the questions we get asked
most often is what's the deal with us
the guys from Freddie w we live together
do we work together do you work on each
other's videos what's going on even more
i have friends we've been v I wouldn't
yeah in high school blue stuff up in his
backyard together at stuff certain
things on part or whatever made short
action for ya you know also stuff we do
now but on a high school scale yeah
exactly Brandon really didn't know much
about the effects and stuff actually
back then it seems crazy but basically
we just worked with him for almost a
full year and we tried to just teach him
everything we know about anything and
they started their YouTube channel and
we just kept doing it we were there
still doing freelance VFX and so we
would be basically just be passing tips
back and forth on how to do different
you know effects and things like that
and I say as we gave the mobs for how to
do the effects yeah they were giving us
tips on their strategies that they're
trying with their YouTube to yeah
exactly because then they had a head
start on their channel and they
basically we were learning things about
how the online video world was working
as we were finishing all these VFX like
gigs
gotcha you gotta reset the game I got
you man hold on help
I'd like to imagine there's a secret
formula that only we know but it's
actually really obvious but obviously
and it's all you know this is all under
the umbrella of making sure you have a
good execution on the idea but
regardless it is you know we got a
variety of video game characters
featured in this video and that means
even if you're not a fan of Minecraft
your fan of Mario and if you're not a
fan Mario you're a fan of Master Chief
so it's like you're gonna like something
in this and in his now experience yeah
it has that common experience in your
games every video gamer knows about just
yeah so so basically we're taking a
variety of video game characters taking
a very basic common experience that
affects all these video games
essentially and then a bunch of the
effect and then throw in a bunch of the
effects through and make it really epic
really yeah really epic epic it's always
got to be this is the most epic thing
that's ever happened and make it funny
and it's aunt a little bit of comedy in
there too so like the instakill videos
it meets all those requirements to its
variety of video game characters um tons
of the effects it's super epic gives its
two people constantly switching
characters and trying to you know leave
insta kill each other and then it's a
little bit funny too I think yeah it is
is it funny it's more stylish and funny
but you know it's naturally Megan
smooshed by the blue shell yes is that
funny but it's really well if you think
Gore is funny then it's really funny
advantages you get to make whatever you
want and no one is your boss okay
disadvantages is you're not making that
much money off your videos and you don't
have enough budget to make anything
other than a quick little video it's
like we're making granted their shirt
you know a lot shorter than TV show but
you know making videos that get as many
hits as you know a very popular cable
television show or even like a TV show
on you know the standard ABC CBS NBC
networks so we're making Clips are
getting millions of views but our
budgets are still only a thousand bucks
and that's if we spend every dollar we
make yeah we already off video for
spaying a thousand dollars on it yeah
yeah that's yeah so that's that's the
downside of YouTube isn't that the money
is not there yet with the advertising
and you can you really go out there like
seek out sponsorships but it's so
incredibly hard to find a company that
is going to let you make a video that
doesn't feel like an advertisement and
still feel like they're getting their
money's worth so little by little as you
to be hopefully evolves and gets CPM is
higher and gets those budgets higher you
know then the can't go see the content
evolve it's the reason you're not seeing
a lot of people are doing what we're
doing is because it's very hard to
afford a nice camera a nice set of
lenses and those computers and a team of
people when you're making a CPM of a
buck you know per thousand so it's not
until you see that go up but you're
going to see some stuff changes that's
certainly a disadvantage of YouTube mega
mega advantage is directly connection
with the audience annoying right away
what people like and what they don't
like and you have to read read into it a
little bit people aren't sitting down
and busting out you know a Roger Ebert
level critique of the inside to your
film and how it flows they're saying
that was good or this part was boring
and see if you figure out what's
inspiring that but if you see a common
thread with you know people on the film
in the comments section that helps you
learn as an artist like for example with
the Zelda video just came out
we knew that if he didn't get links look
correct and dark links look correct that
people would they just merely be
distracted by the piece and so you know
we put all you know we've made this
costume for a lot of time and effort to
you know crashing the look at this piece
and the question is did we pull it off
and based on the comments section for
dark think we did but for late people
thought was a little bit hit and miss
that's also going to be a little bit
naturally the case when people are
watching something because everybody has
their own version of who these
characters are although at the end of
the day I think what was more important
to the audience based on the top
comments is that we left lens on one of
the rocks in a shot
the network system on YouTube can be
helpful and it can really be great for
people who are trying to start off and
make a living and get off the ground but
there's a there's a very I guess deep
problem in it and that is pretty much
everybody that goes out and says hey
join our network they promise that
they'll provide certain amounts of
support and we'll try to help you grow
your channel you know that there's a
team of other channels there that can
help that can work with you that's true
to some degree but once you start
signing on more than 10 channels into a
network and every network has more than
10 channels out there's no way you can
work with all those people in any kind
of close matter it's if you sign down a
thousand channels into your network
everybody's been signed on with the
promise that this network is there to
support them but if a thousand people
need just a 5-minute call with the
person managing them at the network
there's not enough time in a week to you
know call a thousand different channels
and manage although there's no way to
keep track of that yeah like last year
we were very focused on like subscriber
based stuff we're like we're so worried
about these numbers and rankings and
stuff like this but this year it's kind
of like man like your ranks but like the
only thing that matters is like if
people are liking the videos you're
making and like if you're enjoying what
you're doing it doesn't matter if you're
like the lowest subscribe YouTube
channel on youtube if every video you
make its view some people like it mm-hmm
you know that's that's really what comes
down to its it's not it's not as
competitive as television because you're
not a time slot against another show
it's like which we're not going to watch
I can only pick one you know with
YouTube it's like that's cool video
that's another cool video yeah I'm gonna
watch that video now and you don't
you're not really competing with other
people also subscriber numbers I think
are a little overrated frankly like we
even though like it even happens today
where it's like oh we have so many
subscribers but it's like liked it not
even any of them like really
consistently watched our videos like we
have two million subscribers but you
know like when we put a video it's not
like they'll see it
they all go and watch it you don't need
two million views we don't get to a
million views in the first day or first
week you know so it's like you know the
it's not like they don't have value but
it's not like but it's not that it
doesn't determine the success of your
videos or your channel so it helps it
helps his backer it's a factor hey it's
not the designing back yeah it's not
gonna make a break it yeah so long story
short I'd say people can look forward to
us hopefully starting to evolve and move
into the next step of the art form and
of our careers as the year progresses
and we go into next year well it's safe
to say also that we have plans also
later this fall to put some pretty big
videos out fingers crossed obviously but
on our channel on our channel but uh
we're gonna have we're going to have a
bunch of really kind of like funny more
like classic videos on our channel this
summer and then when the fall comes
around we got some like really really
really big projects coming out so I'm
very excited for it